[Music]
what up guys goes in here what a crazy
episode this was an attack on Titan the
second last episode of the season so
we're switching things up a bit today
instead of doing a live reaction I
decided to do a review but if you want
to share your thoughts or questions just
leave them in the comment section below
and I'll be sure to read them if anyone
is new to the channel be sure to
subscribe we got a lot of attack on
Titan content on this channel and many
more videos to come but wow guys it's
getting crazy so we started out this
episode with Reiner the armored Titan
carrying Bertolt a tied-up air and
Aamir's Titan and historian who has been
in a Mears mouth since last episode
because is now so close to getting Aaron
back and she's ready to kill anyone in
her way even a mere and historian if she
continues to get in her way this is
actually one of my favorite parts in the
manga where Mikasa says that she can
only care for so many people she has
only so much room in her heart and she
chose who those people were long ago and
she's of course talking about Armin and
mainly Eren but let's look at a mirror
and historians conversation in this
episode for a second which was very
interesting
Amir says that there's no future inside
the walls and that historian will be
treated better outside the walls so at
this point it's pretty clear that there
is more than just Titans outside the
walls if we take the fact that Reiner
and Bertolt want to return to their
hometown as they run further from the
walls and Aamir's backstory from last
episode we can conclude that there do
seem to be people outside the walls
which is huge information but just
quickly
Aamir's backstory by the way was only
revealed a few chapters ago into manga
which is way ahead of the anime so I
still don't know how I feel about them
doing that let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below but it
definitely has created for a very
interesting season so far
anyways Amir tries to tell historian
that she has to come or they will kill
her they will find her and kill her
again we have a clue of people existing
beyond the walls and that they want to
kill Amir for stealing the Titan power
from Ryder's friend Marcel historia
agrees because she is ever the selfless
person
especially when it comes to a mere
despite her seemingly selfless request
his story agrees and says that no matter
what she will be her ally however during
the fight the two get separated and
Connie picks up historia with the help
of Sasha and Connie his storia figures
out that everything Aamir ever did was
for her story of safety so she's
obviously lying about needing her to
live she just wants to keep the story of
safe you gotta love how Amir such a
seemingly cold character is actually one
of the most selfless and caring people
in the show that's what I'm all about
attack on Titan it always subvert our
expectations in one way or another
speaking of subverting expectations we
also got some interesting information
from Berthold the other members called
him out saying to think an invader could
sleep like a log next to his victims
Versalles and Reiner definitely seemed
like evil scum at this point they
pretended to be friends with everyone
spoke of the future and getting through
this together while they were the ones
who broke down the wall and killed so
many innocent people including people's
family members Berthold finally freaks
out and says that he feels terrible he
didn't want to do it but people despise
us so the million-dollar question is
what does he mean by us and then he says
his only respite was pretending to be a
soldier he tries to say that their
friendship was real but someone has to
do what he's doing even though he hates
it Armin also figures out that Berthold
likes Annie and uses that information
and says they are torturing her better
told freaks out showing he is human and
does indeed care about his friends but
the question for anime watchers remains
why did he and the rest of them do it
why do they want Eren if you guys can't
wait or have read the manga already you
can check out my coordinate explained
video to find out why this is now let's
talk about
erlin for a little bit oh my god what a
beast he is Erlin is definitely the star
of this episode from the beginning we
see him thinking on his feet or horse I
guess but you know what I mean he act
quickly and comes up with a plan to
guide the horde of titans into reiner
one of my favorite parts in this episode
is when someone asks is this hell and
Irwin
replies no but it will be charged what
an epic line I mean that's our arrows
will blot out the Sun then we will find
the shade level of Awesome Earl and then
out of nowhere loses an arm and we're
like whoa we expect him to cry out or
yell but he is on phase and just screams
at the hand now that alone cemented him
as a sick character but it doesn't stop
there he's also the one who comes out of
nowhere later on having escaped from the
Titans and rescues Aaron before causing
a retreat all of that with a freshly
lost arm in saying stuff guys this guy
is my new hero no doubt so then before
our characters can escape
Reiner starts throwing Titans at them
like a maniac in the confusion Eren and
Mikasa fall and then the biggest flaw of
the episode is dropped we see the
smiling Titan approaching them the same
one that killed Aaron's mom and that's
when it ends oh my god this is going to
be crazy for those of you who read the
manga you know how epic this finale is
going to be and people who haven't trust
me it's going to be insane I can't wait
for next week I'm just so sad at the
seasons almost over and we may have to
wait a long time for the next one but at
least we have manga chapters coming out
each month but Wow overall this episode
was amazing and it's leading up
beautifully third season finale tell me
what you guys thought of the episode in
the comment section below
did you miss Levi or did early epicness
make up for his absence if you enjoyed
this episode make sure to go erwin mode
on that like button and subscribe for
all kinds of attack on titan videos
until next time see us space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]